There was more Olympic Games history as the women navigated the skateboarding course...
...at Tokyo 2020 for the first time.
This was the Women's Street final.
Judges assessing the rider's stance, spins, grinds and slides.
Skateboarding legend Tony Hawk, a pioneer of the sport, was watching closely.
It came down to a battle of the 13-year-olds.
Brazil's Rayssa Leal had impressed and was looking for a golden performance in her last run.
But, she couldn't nail the landing.
And that meant Nishiya Momiji was in a position to capture Olympic glory on home soil.
And she did.
The 13-year-olds finishing 1-2.
At 16 years of age,  Japan's Nakayama Funa took bronze.